so what is the bar we should set what
what is the strategy that we should have
maybe it is time for someone like
McCarthy or someone that could
potentially be more influential than
McCarthy to say enough is enough we will
have to deal with some temporary pain
but we will do the right thing here's
Governor Ron DeSantis in Iowa yesterday
uh discussing the cowardice of D.C
Republicans and what the Fallout is
going to be because of this deal
we now see Washington is now cooked up
their latest quote debt deal and I can
tell you this our nation was careening
towards bankruptcy before the debt deal
and it will still be careening towards
bankruptcy after this debt deal this is
green lighting four trillion dollars in
new debt in less than two years it took
us almost 200 years to get to 4 trillion
in debt in the first place it locks in
inflated covid level uh era levels of
spending and it keeps 98 of the 87 000
new IRS agents that Joe Biden instituted
this this is not going to solve our
nation's fiscal problems I can tell you
in Florida we run budget surpluses we
have a 1.2 trillion dollar GDP in
Florida we'd be the 13th largest economy
in the world if we were our separate
country and yet with 1.2 trillion
economy our state debt is only 17
billion dollars
okay you really need to understand the
numbers there right so we have an
incredible GDP here in Florida we have
low debt related to that and what that
then allows is for economic growth and
when you have economic growth and more
people start doing what they want to do
and it actually becomes I would say
spiritual and cultural in nature when
the government has gotten out of your
way because it is acted uh trimly and
effectively you can then do what you
want to do build the type of life that
you want to live and I'm pretty sure
that is the whole point of of the whole
freaking thing it has something to do
with that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]